red-eyed tree frogs live in a canopy of
the Panamanian rainforest when it comes
time to make both parties do what it
takes to find a convivial spot
if the female chooses a place that's too
low her brood could be washed away by
the next tropical storm this is a rain
forest don't forget but the home must
overhang upon so the tadpoles can
ker-plop into the water when they're
ready she carries the mail around
piggyback style until she finds her
dream leaf she starts laying her 32:58
the frog eggs are encased in a
jelly-like mass in an astonishing
time-lapse shot we see the eggs evolving
into tadpoles they're almost ready to be
on their own and none too soon a hungry
vine snake 3 feet of elegant ravenous
death slithers toward the eggs
here's the egg in four days a
recognizable tadpole it's ready to hatch
and drop into the water but there are
fish just waiting for a plump delicious
helpless tadpole talk about fate the
possibility of being gobbled by a vine
snake versus the possibility of being
thrown into the water into the mouth of
a waiting predator below
and then there's this Dragonfly nymph
one of the fiercest scariest hungriest
creatures in this ecosystem how do you
like your first and last memory of life
to be this face and yet can we leave you
on a happy note some tadpoles will avoid
instant death grow into adult redeye
tree frogs and take to the trees where
this whole cycle can begin again